[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
mietri Serin schönen guten Abend
Christian Ottos wieder mit mir im Studio
und hat später das Wichtigste vom Sport
sehr spannend die Champions League
Auslosung guten Abend dann blicken wir
jetzt gemeinsam auf die Themen an diesem
Donnerstag
viel Kritik nach ampelklausur in
Meseberg
Opposition und Wirtschaft gehen die
Beschlüsse nicht weit genug
Hilferuf aus Sachsen die Schleuse und
geflüchtete hat stark zugenommen der
Landesinnenminister schickt mehr Polizei
an die Grenze
Großbrand in Johannesburg mehr als 70
Menschen sterben sie hatten offenbar
illegal in einem offiziell unbewohnten
Haus gelebt
[Musik]
um den Wirtschaftsmotor anzuschmeißen
setzen grüne auf Subventionen die FDP
auf Steuersenkungen und das wurde heute
auch auf den Klausuren der
Regierungsparteien deutlich insofern ist
es geräuschlose auftreten dass sich die
Ampel in Meseberg verordnete
wahrscheinlich endlich viele Betriebe
sind jedenfalls enttäuscht von der
Wirtschaftspolitik der Ampel die
oppositionelle Union erst recht Klaus
brotbeck
wieder gehen sie in Klausuren im
Sauerland heute die Union
Fraktionsvorstand Schmallenberg Stadt
Meseberg was die Ampel zur Belebung der
Wirtschaft beschlossen habe Ihnen hier
viel zu wenig
ich sag's mal mit meinen Worten das
Wachstums Original in Deutschland sind
wir die CDU und die CSU wir haben in
schwierigen Zeiten in Deutschland immer
bewiesen dass wir eine
wachstumsorientierte Wirtschaftspolitik
können Deutschland befindet sich in
einer
Abwärtsspirale von Inflation Rezession
und auch heute sehr deutlich steigender
Arbeitslosigkeit und die Ampel hat
wiederum den Zeitpunkt verstreichen
lassen
für die zweite Jahreshälfte die
notwendigen Entscheidungen zu treffen in
Nürnberg Tagen die Grünen und
wiederholen dort ihre in der Koalition
umstrittene Forderung mit einem
industriestrompreis energieintensive
Unternehmen zeitweise zu entlasten Sie
wissen dass
es mehr als
überhörbar unüberhörbar ist dass die
Energiepreise massiv drücken die
Unternehmen sehr darunter leiden und
natürlich wird das mittelfristig nur
funktionieren mit massiven Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren auf dem Weg dahin wollen
wir vor allem die Grundstoffindustrie in
diesem Land schützen das stößt doch
Widerstand beim Kanzler und bei der FDP
wie die Union fordern auch die Liberalen
heute in Dresden Atomkraftwerke wieder
in Betrieb zu nehmen
es geht um arbeiten um erwirtschaften
und bessere Standortbedingungen das ist
der Fokus der Koalition in den kommenden
zwei Jahren aus meiner Sicht weitere
Sozialleistungen lehnt die FDP ab
miteinander in Meseberg das war gestern
ja die Ampel hatte in Meseberg zum
Beispiel verbesserte
Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten beim
Wohnungsbau auf den Weg gebracht aber
die Branche die schreit jetzt nicht
unbedingt hurra weil deren Probleme nach
diversen Krisen ziemlich komplex sind
wir uns jetzt Markus woll sie verzeigt
die Firma Brömer in Wiesbaden hat
turbulente Zeiten hinter sich Corona
Lieferengpässe hohe Energiekosten und
schließlich die Zinswende teure Kredite
lassen die Nachfrage sinken die Branche
spricht bereits von einer
stornierungswelle die Verunsicherung ist
riesengroß ich will Ihnen dann aktuelles
Beispiel nennen wir sind seit einem
knappen Jahr waren wir im Austausch mit
mit einem Bauern bis es dann erst zur
Auftragserteilung kam üblicherweise
laufen solche Verhandlungen innerhalb
von vielleicht drei Wochen ab mit dem
wachstumschancengesetz will die
Bundesregierung die kriselnde Baubranche
entlasten um insgesamt 540 Millionen
Euro im Entwurf ist die Rede von einer
geometrische degressiven Abschreibung
für Gebäude mit fallenden
Jahresbeiträgen übersetzt heißt das
Investoren sollen die Kosten schneller
beim Finanzamt geltend machen können das
hilft die Steuerlast zu senken der
Gesetzentwurf sieht einen Satz von 6 %
vor befristet auf sechs Jahre die
erleichterten Abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
sollen für Wohngebäude mit Baubeginn ab
1 Oktober gelten
die Branche sieht darin allenfalls einen
guten Anfang ein Problem aber bleibt
bevor man abschreibt muss man erstmal
investiert haben und wenn die Kosten so
hoch sind dass die Wohnungsunternehmen
nicht investieren können helfen auch die
Abschreibungen nicht wichtig sein
liquide Mittel zu Beginn eines Projekts
andernfalls waren die Branche sei es
kaum möglich bezahlbares Wohnen zu
finanzieren die Unternehmen fordern noch
mehr Unterstützung für den 25 September
hat Kanzler Scholz zum baugipfel geladen
die Arbeitslosigkeit in Deutschland hat
im August weiter zugenommen Gründe sind
der übliche Anstieg während der
Sommerpause aber auch die
Konjunkturflaute zudem wirkt sich die
Zahl ukrainischer geflüchtete auf die
Statistik aus laut Bundesagentur für
Arbeit waren im August 2 Millionen 696
000 Menschen ohne Job das sind 79.000
mehr als im Juli die Arbeitslosenquote
liegt bei 5,8 % im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
waren rund
148.000 Menschen mehr ohne Arbeit
es gibt neues in der bayerischen
flugblattaffäre freie wählerchef
Aiwanger hat sich heute erstmals
entschuldigt er bereue zutiefst wenn er
durch sein Verhalten in Bezug auf das
antisemitische Flugblatt oder weitere
Vorwürfe aus der Jugendzeit Gefühle
verletzt habe sagte er in München seine
Entschuldigung gelte vor allem allen
Opfern des NS-Regimes und deren
Hinterbliebenen Aiwanger Beklagte
gleichzeitig eine nicht akzeptable
politische Kampagne gegen sich und seine
Partei er habe das Flugblatt nicht
verfasst und können sich nicht daran
erinnern als Schüler den Hitlergruß
gezeigt zu haben
seit Wochen warnen Polizeigewerkschaften
und Landespolitiker es kommen immer mehr
illegale Flüchtlinge nach Deutschland
betroffen sind vor allem die Grenzen im
Süden und im Osten Beispiel Sachsen dort
gab es in diesem Jahr über 12.000
erlaubte einreisen sind mehr als doppelt
so viele wie 2022 besonders über die
Autobahnen aus Polen und Tschechien
Sachsens Innenminister schickt jetzt
darum mehr Polizisten an die Grenzen
Steffi Moritz Müller
ein fast alltägliches Bild nahe der
polnischen und tschechischen Grenze in
Sachsen 26 Männer Frauen und Kinder
eingepfercht in einem kleinen
Transporter ohne Wasser und Essen für
tausende Euro von Schleusern nach
Deutschland gebracht unter
lebensgefährlichen Umständen da die
Schleuse Kriminalität stark zunimmt will
Sachsen jetzt die Schleierfahndung
verstärken
deswegen habe ich jetzt
Bereitschaftspolizei ins
grenz-hinterland in Abstimmung mit der
Bundespolizei geschickt wir wollen den
Druck auf die Schleuser deutlich erhöhen
und ich muss auch klar sagen die Art und
Weise wie unkontrolliert sich das jetzt
über die Grenzen entwickelt das können
wir so nicht stehen lassen man hat das
Gefühl die Schleuser bestimmen wenn nach
Deutschland kommt und deswegen haben wir
gesagt dem Treiben müssen wir jetzt ein
Signal entgegensetzen
gefahndet wird ab sofort auch in Zivil
das ist schon erschreckend sage ich mal
wieder mit welcher brachialen Gewalt da
die Schleuse zu Berge gehen weil die
versuchen dort einfach wirklich nur sich
der Polizei in Kontrolle zu entziehen
und überlassen letztendlich die
basilisierung dort im Fahrzeug ihrem
Schicksal schon jetzt sind in diesem
Jahr mehr als doppelt so viele
eingereist wie im gleichen Zeitraum des
Vorjahres deshalb fordert Sachsen schon
seit Monaten dass die Bundesregierung
endlich grünes Licht für temporäre
Grenzkontrollen gibt
heute haben Polizisten wieder zwei
Schleuser und dutzende Flüchtlinge
aufgegriffen die meisten von ihnen
kommen nach eigenen Angaben aus Syrien
Afghanistan und der Türkei dabei stehen
die Monate mit den erfahrungsgemäß
höchsten Flüchtlingszahlen erst noch
bevor
ja die anwachsenden Zahlen illegale
Einwanderungen nehmen die Kollegen von
heute live gleich ab 19.30 noch mal
genauer in den Blick auf unseren Social
Media Kanälen bzw in unserer ZDF heute
App
jetzt blicken wir nach Afrika in ein
Land in dem man blutiger Machtkampf tobt
in den Sudan
2021 putschte dort das Militär danach
entbrannte ein Konflikt zwischen zwei
generellen der im April eskalierte und
seitdem kämpft die Armee und der macht
aber al Burhan gegen seinen ehemaligen
Vize daglow und dessen paramilitärische
Miliz mehr als 4 Millionen Menschen sind
auf der Flucht und die Vereinten
Nationen warnen vor einer humanitären
Katastrophe
zu tun
die paramilitärische Truppe hat die
Hauptstadt seit April besetzt bewiesene
tote Körper sollen überall in der Stadt
offen rumliegen was passiert wenn man
zwischen die Fronten gerät das hat Hagar
erlebt Hagar hier gefesselt in blau
verhaftet von den Paramilitärs die ihm
vorwerfen die Armee zu unterstützen im
ZDF-Interview erzählt er von
stundenlanger
sie kamen mit Stromkabeln und
Vorhangstangen damit schlugen sie uns
während sie das Kommando gaben Aufstehen
kriech spring nach dahinten
die Vereinten Nationen werfen den
Paramilitärs rohe Gewalt dazu
Vergewaltigung und sexuelles Sklaverei
von Frauen und Mädchen mehr als 100
Fällen vor wir treffen eine von ihnen
die Erinnerung ist unerträglich drei
Soldaten sollen sie gleichzeitig
missbraucht haben
mein Mann war dabei die Nachbarn sie
waren alle dabei
doch weil Vergewaltigung im Sudan als
Schande angesehen wird hat er Ehemann
seine Frau und die drei Kinder verstoßen
sie ist nun alleine auf der Flucht und
vergeblich auf der Suche nach
medizinischer Versorgung ein Großteil
der Krankenhäuser geschlossen besonders
hart trifft das die Kinder
Hunderttausenden droht der Hungertod
eine von ihnen ist Omnia seit 20 Tagen
wartet die dreieinhalbjährige in dem
Krankenhaus auf Behandlung
wir wollen dass unsere Kinder ganz
normal aufwachsen können aber die
Zukunft unserer Kinder ist zerstört
im Sudan schwindet die Hoffnung die
humanitäre Krise spitzt sich immer
weiter zu
[Musik]
johannesburg ist geschockt und trauert
im Zentrum der südafrikanischen
Metropole wütete einer der tödlichsten
wohnhausbrände weltweit mindestens 74
Menschen kamen dabei ums Leben dutzende
wurden verletzt offiziell stand das
fünfstöckige Gebäude leer wurde aber von
hunderten illegal bewohnt Verena Garrett
besetzte Gebäude hat verfallen illegal
vermietet davon gibt es viele in
Johannesburg Innenstadt wer hier lebt
ist von der Gesellschaft vergessen
Menschen ohne Pass ohne Papiere ohne
Aufenthaltsgenehmigung
aber wir haben keine Wahl wir haben
keinen guten Job und nicht genug Geld
für ein teures zu Hause
David alabi bankt um seine Schwester
zwei Brüder seinen Schwager sie lebten
in dem Haus in dem sich heute Nacht das
Feuer ausbreitete und werden immer noch
vermisst
hunderte Menschen auf engstem Raum weil
sie sonst nirgendwo hin konnten so war
es auch hier die Miete unter der Hand
gezahlt Strom und Wasser nicht vorhanden
die Gebäude marode und die Stadt hat
bisher nichts gegen die kriminellen
Vermieter getan
losigkeit in Johannesburg nimmt zu wir
sagen immer wieder haltet euch von den
Gebäuden fern aber man erreicht die
Menschen nicht mehr das Justizsystem
lässt uns im Stich man müsste die
Besetzer identifizieren und bestrafen
eine Nachlässigkeit die mit die Ursache
dafür sein könnte dass viele Menschen in
der vergangenen Nacht ihr Leben verloren
haben
der Clan des tschetschenenführers
kadirov ist mächtig in Russland und
gefürchtet auch bei Oppositionellen die
es ins Ausland geschafft haben und deren
Angst ist berechtigt so sieht es das
Münchner Oberlandesgericht es vor zu
urteilte heute einen Mann zu zehn Jahren
Haft weil er den Mord an einem
Regime-Gegner in Deutschland vorbereitet
haben soll im letzten Moment scheiterte
das Attentat mehr dazu jetzt von Samuel
Kirsch
er sollte ermordet werden mochmat
abdurach mannov sitzt heute dem Mann
gegenüber der seine Tötung plante 2017
Flo er von Tschetschenien nach Bayern
sein Leben geriet in Gefahr weil er es
wagte ihn zu kritisieren Ramsan kadirov
Diktator von Putins Gnaden in der
russischen Teilrepublik Tschetschenien
aus seinem Machtapparat kam der Befehl
abdurach manno im Exil in Deutschland
umbringen zu lassen denn Mord
organisieren sollte Walid D der Plan
flog auf es blieb beim Versuch die
Richterinnen und Richter verurteilten
war die Idee heute unter anderem wegen
der Vorbereitung einer schweren
staatsgefährdenden Gewalttat aus
politischen Motiven
das Gericht hat damit den in der Anklage
geschriebenen Vorwurf verwiesen erachtet
dass der Angeklagte im Auftrag des
tschetschenischen Regimes einen in
Deutschland lebenden Exil
Oppositionellen töten sollte die
Verteidigung kündigte Revision an der
Fall ist politisch brisant nach
Recherchen des SPIEGEL war der
Verurteilte Qualität für den
Verfassungsschutz Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
tätig ein Mitarbeiter soll ihm die
Adresse des avisierten Mordopfers
mitgeteilt haben
der Fall wirft Fragen auf warum
arbeitete eine deutsche
Sicherheitsbehörde mit dem kadiruf
Gefolgsmann zusammen ohne von dem Mord
Plan zu erfahren und hat ein Beamter
dieser Behörde tatsächlich Informationen
zu hochgefährdeten Personen
weitergegeben auch nach dem Urteil heute
besteht also Aufklärungsbedarf
völlig anderes Thema der Umweltbonus
also die Förderung für geschäftlich
genutzte Elektroautos läuft heute aus
bis zu 4.500 Euro gab der Staat bis
jetzt dazu für Privatleute gilt das
zunächst weiter wird aber nächstes Jahr
reduziert aber gerade in Firmenwagen
flotten finden sich mit 15%
vergleichsweise viele angetriebene
Fahrzeuge die elektrisch fahren zum
Vergleich bei Privatfahrzeugen sind
gerade einmal 2,3% mehr von Andreas
linke
etwa jedes sechste neu zugelassene
Fahrzeug in Deutschland ist derzeit
elektrisch ein Verhältnis dass ich auch
in den Räumen dieses Stuttgarter
Autohauses spiegelt ein Sechstel
elektrisch doch ohne Förderung für
gewerbliche Fahrzeuge könnte sich das
Verschieben ihr spürt das jetzt bereits
dass ich eine dass ich die Nachfrage
reduziert weil auch im gewerblichen
Bereich ist die Förderung ein Teil der
Finanzierung den Umweltbonus für
E-Fahrzeuge gibt es in unterschiedlicher
Form seit 2016 mit jedem Jahr stieg die
Zahl der Kaufprämien bis Anfang dieses
Jahres Hybridfahrzeuge aus der Förderung
vielen knapp zwei Millionen umweltboni
gab es insgesamt
das bisherige Fördervolumen beträgt 9,2
Milliarden Euro der gewerbliche Anteil
lag etwa bei 55 Prozent die
Autoindustrie hätte gerne an der
Förderung festgehalten gerade im
gewerblichen Bereich wäre ein hoher
Beitrag für den Klimaschutz zu leisten
wir haben hier einen hohen Umschlag und
die Autos würden auch schnell in den
Gebrauchtwagenmarkt gehen also aus
unserer Sicht ein falscher Schritt zur
falschen Zeit aber es gibt für
Unternehmen neben dem Preis weitere
Kaufkriterien ich gehe aber davon aus
dass diese negative Entwicklung ein
wenig gedämpft wird dadurch dass sehr
viele Unternehmen sich zum Ziel gesetzt
haben klimaneutral zu werden und
deswegen auch Elektrofahrzeuge auch ohne
Prämie nachgefragt werden in den flotten
wie sich das Ende der Förderung auf das
Kundenverhalten auswirkt wird dann ein
paar Monaten erkennbar sein
jetzt Christin mit Neuigkeiten von der
Fußballnationalmannschaft der Männer
Wiedergutmachung ist das Ziel der
Erfolgsdruck ist groß zum Einstieg ins
em ja mit Blick auf die ersten Spiele
gegen WM Schreck Japan und den WM
zweiten Frankreich im September und
Bundestrainer haben sie Flick will dabei
auf bewährte und etablierte Spieler
verzichten
Überraschung bei der kardan-nominierung
Leon Goretzka und Timo Werner wurden von
Hansi Flick gestrichen ja trotzdem ist
es so dass im Momentaufnahme und jeder
einzelne der jetzt vielleicht nicht
dabei ist hat immer noch die Chance die
Chance dazu zu stoßen neu dabei ist
Pascal groß er kann als Außenverteidiger
spielen und ist als zentraler
Mittelfeldspieler zum erfolgreichsten
Premier League Schützen von Brighton und
Hof Albion geworden die Hoffnung ist
groß dass er die Nationalmannschaft mit
seinen Knipser Qualitäten bereichert
[Applaus]
ja und so eben ausgelost die
Gruppenphase der neuen Champions League
Saison vier deutsche Club dabei RB
Leipzig bekommt es unter anderem wieder
mit Manchester City zu tun dem Titel
Verteidiger Neuling Union Berlin mit
diesen zwei Favoriten SSC Neapel und
Real Madrid dem Rekord Gewinner bayern
Münchens Aufgaben in der Gruppe A lösbar
aber knifflig mit Manchester United FC
Kopenhagen und Galatasaray Istanbul
hammerloser für Borussia Dortmund mit
Paris St Germa außerdem hat sie Mailand
und Newcastle United das wird nicht
leicht in der Gruppe F los geht's am 19
und 20 September
ja kurz vor Transferschluss steht wohl
auch der Wechsel von Stürmer Niklas
Füllkrug fest nach übereinstimmenden
Medienberichten und endgültig von Werder
Bremen zu Borussia Dortmund
noch keine Top-Leistung aber dennoch ein
gelungener Start für die deutschen
Volleyballspieler bei der
Europameisterschaft in Italien angeführt
von Top-Angreifer Georg großer bezwang
das Team die Auswahl aus Estland in 3 zu
0 setzen am Freitag gegen die Schweiz
müsse man aber noch eine bessere
Leistung abrufen ja schwierige Gruppe
jeder Punkt zählt vielen Dank Christin
zum Schluss haben wir noch ein
besonderes Schauspiel am Himmel gibt's
weltweit zu bestaunen es geht um den
supermond wie gestern in Griechenland
erschien unserer nächtlicher Begleiter
besonders gut groß weil der der Erde
gerade besonders nah ist und das schon
zum zweiten Mal im August und so ein
doppelauftritt des XXL Mondes in einem
Monat kommt nur alle zehn Jahre vor ist
super für alle die eine klare wolkenlose
Sicht hatten
sorry leider war morgen ist
meteorologischer Herbstanfang war
zuletzt ja wirklich herzlich kühl wird
sich aber ändern mehr gleich von Katja
hornefall Arbeitsminister Heil ab 21:40
Uhr im heute journal Interview mit
Christian Sievers das war's von uns
morgen hier Barbara halbweg schönen
Abend und auf bald
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen beginnt
meteorologisch ja der Herbst aber der
Spätsommer der will es bei uns noch mal
wissen was sehen Sie hier schon über
Frankreich da kommt jetzt nämlich eine
Warmfront heran und die kann die
herbstliche Kühle der letzten Tage aus
Deutschland vertreiben die Warenform
bringt schon heute Nacht den ersten
Regen im Südwesten mit Regenschauer
gibt's ja auch nordöstlich der Elbe
dazwischen ist es trocken zum Teil auch
mal klar und dann bildet sich Nebel und
die Temperaturen sinken z.B in der
Lüneburger Heide oder auch im Emsland
bis auf 8 Grad sonst liegen die Werte
meist knapp über zehn Grad am mindestens
bleibt die Nacht am Oberrhein und morgen
erwarten uns Höchsttemperaturen um 20
Grad Richtung Niederbayern und auch am
Oberrhein sind es schon so 24 bis 26
Grad morgen gibt's noch einige
Regenschauer an der Küste sonst beginnt
der Tag in Norddeutschland erstmal ganz
freundlich dann aber sie die wahren
Freund weiter nach Norden und über der
Mitte Deutschlands kann es recht Kräft
IG regnen da sind auch mal Gewitter
dabei nachmittags setzt sich dann hier
von Süden immer häufiger die Sonne durch
bei Südwestwind und in den nächsten
Tagen gibt es immer weniger Regen dafür
mehr Sonnenschein bei Temperaturen von
20 bis 29 Grad guten Abend